we're in the northeast of brazil in the
powell brazil national park
there's a rich variety of nature here
vastly differing ecosystems exist side
by side
for example the mussonunga forest
explains park director fabio farako
the ground is very loose and the trees
have to adapt to that as a result the
trees aren't that close to each other
so more light enters the forest
and other plant species grow like
bromeliads or orchids
there are more than 630 plant species
here
the name of the national park pao brasil
comes from a tree species
centuries ago the portuguese chopped it
down to extract its red pigment
the tree was such an important raw
material back then that the country was
named after it brazil
the pal brazil tree is almost extinct
now it only exists in the national park
where large specimens like this one are
a real sensation
estimate this tree is between 500 and
600 years old so it's a very old tree
it reminds us of the past
the pearl brazil or brazil wood grows
very slowly these small trees are
already 30 to 40 years old
they grow close to the adult tree
when the adult tree dies the younger
trees compete for their place in the sun
the way the powell brazil reproduces can
only be observed here in the national
park
in the past visitors have had to follow
strict rules that's due to change the
park director has invited a group of
cyclists to explore the park as a test
it's due to be fully open to visitors
later this year and bicycles are to play
an important role
these roads were built before the park
was founded 38 kilometers of paths allow
visitors to enjoy nature as one of the
group explains
it's the middle of the summer the
hottest time of the year
but the climate in the forest is very
mild
it's just priceless
you can easily understand why the
climate is so messed up in other places
it's because the forests are
disappearing
but the forests are protected in the pal
brazil national park director fabio
faraco has dedicated his life to that
you